bien pues se trata del ex funcionario de
más alto nivel que está siendo vinculado
al proceso por el caso hay un china para
esto ha sacudido a la clase política
concretamente a su partido al
funcionario institucional y que sigue
bueno pues ahora se inicia el proceso
podrá eventualmente acogerse a un
criterio de oportunidad convertirse en
testigo colaborador o ir a juicio un
juicio en el que se tendrán que
presentar las pruebas después las va a
valorar y va a emitir una sentencia en
caso de ser hallado culpable serían de
varias décadas de acuerdo con los
delitos que se le imputan y este caso se
ha movido rápidamente presentaron un
informe preliminar ya emitieron más de
80 órdenes de captura y capturaron
precisamente al ex fiscal a este ritmo
habrían más detenciones y vinculaciones
por el caso
de hecho hay varias pendientes las más
importantes de una pieza clave se trata
del ex director de la agencia de
investigación criminal thomas seddon
denunció quienes han acusado de
manipular la escena de alterar las
circunstancias y también de tortura él
se encuentra prófugo de la justicia está
en israel y está ya el trámite para
solicitar su extradición a méxico pero
también hay mandos militares señalados
en el informe recientemente presentado
de la comisión de la verdad del caso
ayotzinapa que hay entre ellos un
general el general saavedra y dos
almirantes de la marina involucrados